[Music]
how do you speak to friends or family
members about lifestyle changes that
might help them when is it time to help
and when is it better to let them
struggle and come out of it on their own
don't like I I stay out of giving advice
or trying to change other people and I
try to just keep my side of the street
clean and for people that are interested
happy to share my experience and so
behind all of this is willingness right
willingness is what drives
transformation without willingness and
by willingness I mean that internal
desire to change that is driven from
within the self and not impulse by
something external
any kind of sustainable change is is
impossible perhaps they need to be in
the world and have this experience that
might actually catalyze that internal
willingness right at some point you
don't want to Rob them of that this is
like the hardest thing